verlieren trotz top spieler der beste wm
aller zeiten
das endspiel ausrechnen und noch mehr
fragen werden jetzt beantwortet hier
sind die top 5 science weg zur wm
bei kiel zum science fiction
auf der 5 der wichtigsten science weg
zur fußball-wm 2014 bei der wm 2014
spieltechnik und wissenschaft eine immer
größere rolle
das fängt schon beim wm fußball bazooka
an der aktuelle wm ball hat nämlich eine
besonders stabile flugbahn
das hängt unter anderem mit seiner hülle
zusammen die aus lediglich sechs feldern
besteht
das hat zur folge dass auch die
gesamtlänge seiner nach mit einem meter
98 besonders kurz ist über flattr wird
sich bei diesem ball wohl niemand mehr
beschwert das haben forscher der
universität tsukuba japan herausgefunden
sie haben unterschiedliche bälle mit 632
feldern verglichen und festgestellt dass
die naht länge eine wichtige rolle für
die flugbahn spielt kappus der ball des
confed-cups im letzten jahr flog
deutlich unruhiger
er hatte mit vier metern 47 an mehr als
doppelt so lange
bei tests mit einem schuss roboter
unterschied sich seine flugbahn nach 25
metern distanz um drei meter in der
senkrecht auf der 4
bei der fifa wm gibt es torlinientechnik
bravo tore die keine sind sollten uns
also bei der fußball-weltmeisterschaft
erspart bleiben eingesetzt wird eine
deutsche technik namens gold control das
neu gegründete unternehmen aus würselen
bei aachen hat ein system entwickelt bei
dem das tor jemals von sieben kameras
überwachten sie erkennen dabei ein tor
nur wenn der ball von vorne durch einen
virtuellen vorhang zwischen den latten
und der torlinie fliegt der
schiedsrichter bekommt eine uhr auf der
eben angezeigt wird ob es ein tor auf
englisch kohl war oder nicht hat om tore
sollten also ausgeschlossen sein
auf der 3 wettbetrug ausgeschlossen die
fifa arbeitet bei dieser wm mit
spezieller analysesoftware die
spielmanipulationen aufdecken soll die
software beobachtet die wettquoten und
einsätze weltweit und gleicht sie mit
dem spielgeschehen ab die software
arbeitet dabei mit ähnlichen algorithmen
mit denen auch die wettquoten errechnet
werden und kann so auffälligkeiten aus
den daten herausrechnen faktoren sind
die bisherigen begegnungen der
jeweiligen mannschaften wer die letzten
spiele ergebnisse oder die spielstärke
im heimatland oder im ausland
ich bin mal gespannt ob wir während der
wm etwas von lisa analyse-software
zuhört bekommt und auf der 2 loco soft
was machst du denn hier domenico nötig
denn bei mir du warst auch bei der
politik hat du bist da gespielt du musst
den doch irgendwoher ein ich habe nicht
aus der bahn
klein und überhaupt ja wenn du dich hast
ja ich bin bald mich meiner machen meine
machen abonnieren kommentieren
favorisieren er kennt das spiel machen
wollte vielen dank
wo soll man den geblieben auf der 2 der
verlauf der wm an ausgerechnet werden
wow die arbeitsgruppe für künstliche
intelligenz der freien universität
berlin hat einen simulator für die
fußball-weltmeisterschaft entwickelt
anhand von verschiedenen kriterien
errechnet der simulator
wahrscheinlichkeiten für die teilnahme
an den verschiedenen stufen des turniers
wie zb dem viertelfinale
die software ist dabei über das internet
für jeden zugänglich zum berechnen kann
dabei jeder unterschiedliche kriterien
gewichten so dass der simulator sehr
unterschiedliche ergebnisse liefern kann
mit dabei sind zum beispiel rankings der
mannschaften das durchschnittsalter
marktwert der spieler oder auch der
heimvorteil den sie genutzt oder nicht
genutzt haben der simulator spielt die
wm dann 10.000 mal durch und zeigt die
teilnahme wahrscheinlichkeiten an und
die 1 zu viele topspieler sind schlecht
für die mannschaft
die mitte man kann noch nicht genug
haben falsch eine studie der institute
business school in fontainebleau hat das
jetzt in einer studie erforscht die
business school hat dafür die
qualifikationsphase für die wm 2010 und
14 untersucht für jede mannschaft haben
die wissenschaftler ermittelt wie viele
spieler aus top vereinen kam und wie die
nationalmannschaften dann gespielt haben
das ergebnis ist verblüffend steigt der
anteil von topspielern auf über 60 nimmt
die mannschaftsleistung ab viel hilft
nicht viel zumindest in einer
fußballmannschaft wenn es sich um den
anteil der top spieler handeln das
sollten die wm trainer bei den
mannschaftsaufstellungen in den nächsten
wochen auf jeden fall beachten und wenn
ihr jetzt wissen wollen wieso dominik
den community cup sucht dann schaut euch
dieses video jahren das klärt dieses
rätsel auf und in diesem video könnt ihr
sehen wie ich beim community cup als
handicap eingewechselt wurde
na ja sehr lustig allerdings wie immer
in der video beschreibung und wenn euch
das video gefallen hat freue ich mich
über ein kostenloses abo und wie immer
heißt es zum schluss bis dann bleibt an